for retirement without worry about 65
million Americans are part of Generation
X and they will be the next generation
to retire a recent TD Ameritrade survey
finds many feel uneasy about it only 33
percent of Gen X workers expect to be
very secure in retirement almost half
worried about running out of money CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here good morning good morning so
what's the key thing to remember let's
be incremental I know it feels daunting
to maybe run even a calculation and you
see what how much you have to do but
really the key here is to start start
early and a little bit at a time and
also recognize this the longer you work
the better off all of this really does
end up meaning that I know everyone's
all I want to retire early but you know
if you look at retiring say instead of
at 62 extend that by say four years you
will have a third better lifestyle in
retirement so working longer works now
with a caveat you can't count on working
because maybe your boss doesn't want you
or maybe you can't physically do it so
we want you to save but also consider
with a life expectancy a little bit
longer these days to keep working so I'm
in Gen X and you now are telling me I've
got to work more yes thanks Joe the
other thing though is isn't everybody
always worried about retirement
absolutely only if you're on easy street
do you think yep got it ready I'm done
and even if you are uneasy Street there
are other things that are making you
nutty so the reality is that we are
concerned about retirement and yet every
survey that we look at shows that in
fact we're worried about retirement but
we don't do anything about it so and I
think the reason we don't is because
we're really scared of stepping on the
scale to use the diet analogy and so the
reality is for most people again doing a
little bit meaning Auto enroll in your
401k and try to do maybe 1% extra every
single year and the most you possibly
can it doesn't have to be the max but
you know you can put eighteen thousand
five hundred dollars into your 401k do
the best you can you don't have to max
out this minute but you have to try to
get there so when it comes to debts what
should you pay off now and how much do
you think you need to put aside I know
it varies depending on your lifestyle I
think that the the number
one priority is always that consumer
debt so it's credit card debt or auto
loans that have higher interest rates so
you start highest interest rate go to
lowest interest rate then you have that
emergency reserve fund that emergency
reserve fund should be anywhere from six
to twelve months don't give me your I
know what you're gonna say to me it's
too hard to do six to twelve months you
always tell me that but that's we're
striving for that we're say that this
time but I not heard you I heard you
think it and then try to max out and by
and large please I know people want to
actually claim Social Security early try
to wait until your full retirement age
the numbers work better all right Jill
Thanks